RIGHT WHERE YOU LEFT OFF YOU
KILL THE TONIGHT HANNITY.
SEE YOU TOMORROW I'M
LAURA INGRAHAM THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT WORKING TO
GET THE LATEST DESPERATE MOVE IN
MOMENTS, BUT FIRST THE GREAT
UNRAVELING THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
♪ ♪
>> Laura: VERY FRUSTRATED BY
THIS DISASTROUS POLL NUMBERS,
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN JOKED ABOUT
NOT LEAVING HER UP TODAY.
>> President Biden: THERE IS
AN OLD EXPRESSION CLAYMONT,
DELAWARE, A SMALL STEEL TOWN
THIS IT WILL EXPLORE RELATIVES
WE STAY LONGER THAN WE SHOULD.
SO BE CAREFUL WE MAY NOT GO
BACK.
>> Laura: I COULDN'T BRANDT
BLAME HIM HIDING OUT IN EUROPE
WILL BE A LOT MORE PREFERABLE TO
COMING BACK HOME.
AND FACING THE WRATH OF AMERICA.
AT WHAT YOU ARE WITNESSING IS A
GREAT UNRAVELING OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
85% OF AMERICA NOW BELIEVES OF
THE COUNTRY IS MOVING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION INCLUDING A
WHOPPING 78% OF DEMOCRATS.
SO IT'S MAKING PEOPLE'S A
PESSIMISTIC?
SOME NEW DATA POINT TO THE
ECONOMY NOT CULTURAL ISSUES COME
IN ON JANUARY 6.
67% OF AMERICANS SAY THAT GAS
PRICES ARE CAUSING FINANCIAL
PAIN.
62% SAY THAT THE PRICE OF GAS
MEANS THAT THEY'RE DRIVING LESS
A 55% SAY THAT GAS PRICES ARE
FORCING THEM TO CHANGE THEIR
VACATION PLANS.
IT GETS EVEN EARLIER BECAUSE
TODAY WE FOUND OUT THAT THE
JOE BIDEN ECONOMY GET THIS,
CONTRACTED MORE IN QUARTER ONE
PREVIOUS ESTIMATES.
SO NOW IT'S A 1.6% ANNUALIZED
DECLINE NOT GOOD.
NOW, IT'S HORRIBLE BUT THE GUY
WHO MISSED INFLATION A YEAR AGO
WE WERE WORRYING ABOUT IT AS YOU
RECALL SAID DON'T WORRY BE
HAPPY.
>> THE U.S. ECONOMY IS IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
STRENGTH OF THE ECONOMY,
HOUSEHOLDS ARE IN VERY GOOD
FINANCIAL SHAPE THE SAME IS TRUE
OF BUSINESSES.
>> TALK ABOUT OUT OF TOUCH.
VERY MISLEADING FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: HE WAS REACQUAINTED
BY CONGRESS FOR ANOTHER TERM.
YOU JUST CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
ZERO ACCOUNT ABILITY EVER IN
THIS ADMINISTRATION FOR GETTING
THINGS WRONG IT'S WHAT THEY DO A
LOT.
AND WITH ALL THIS BAD NEWS AT
SWIRLING AROUND DEMOCRATS ARE
GETTING INCREASINGLY ANNOYED
MAYBE YOU NOTICE THIS THE
WHITE HOUSE IS LAME P.R. MOVE
DEMOCRAT CONGRESS THEY SNIPE
THEM THAT THEY THINK ULTRA MEGA
IS NOT A GOOD TALKING POINT.
ONCE DEMOCRAT STRATEGISTS SAID
THAT THE PRICE HIKES ARE NOT
MEETING VOTERS WITH E.R.
IT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS UNDETERRED BETWEEN
TODAY THAT THE ULTRA MEGA AGENDA
HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT TAKE AWAY
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
IN EVERY SINGLE STATE.
OKAY, IT'S ALSO SO DUMB THAT IT
IS SET AT THIS POINT.
THE ONLY SENSIBLE CONCLUSION HAS
TO BE THAT THE JOE BIDEN PEOPLE
ARE KIND OF ENJOYING THIS IT'S
MASOCHIST IS.
AT SOME LEVEL THEY HAVE TO BE
RELISHING AMERICA'S PAIN
REJOICING ALMOST IN THE FACT
THAT OUR WORKERS LOOSEN GOOD
PAYING JOBS IN THE OIL GAS
INDUSTRY.
>> WE JUST HAD A RECENT REPORT
IS WITHOUT SHOWING ALL OF THE
ENERGY IN THE EMPLOYMENT FROM
LAST YEAR'S.
CLEAN ENERGY AS WIND, FLOSS
FOSSIL FUELS IS LOSING.
>> Laura: WHAT A LOVELY WOMAN
THAT THEY HAVE FORGOTTEN THE
WORKING IN AMERICA.
ARIZONA G.O.P. CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE RENEE LOPEZ WROTE IN
"NEWSWEEK" ATROPHIC PEACE SEVEN
AMERICAN FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING
RATHER THAN ADDRESS THE ISSUES
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS HAVE
ASKED THE WORKING TO SACRIFICE
MORE WHILE LIBERAL CELEBRITIES
DISMISS THE CONCERNS EVEN POKE
FUN AT THOSE FEELING THE IMPACT.
100% CORRECT NO RELIEF AT ALL
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HURTING, BUT DEMOCRATS HAVE A
LOT OF TIME TO CATER TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE RADICAL LEFT.
CASE IN POINT WHILE THEY WON'T
OPEN UP MORE FEDERAL LAND FOR
DRILLING THEY ARE PUSHING FOR A
TRANSGENDER BILL OF RIGHTS,
BECAUSE AMERICANS THAT THE BE
CLAMORING FOR GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE GENDER IDENTITIES TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE 1964 CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT.
BUT THAT AT THE TOP YOUR LIST.
I DEMOCRATS TRYING TO LOSE AS
MANY BATTLES AS POSSIBLE
NOVEMBER?
>> EVERY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE IS
LIFE-SAVING.
MEDICALLY NECESSARY
AGE-APPROPRIATE AND CRITICAL
TOOL FOR HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AS A PEDIATRICIAN WHEN IT COMES
TO MAKING SURE OUR KIDS ARE
HEALTHY AND HAPPY I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT TO EARN SOMEONE'S
TRUE IDENTITY CAN BE.
>> Laura: WOW AT THE GOAL HERE
IS INSIDIOUS IS NOT ABOUT
EQUALITY, IT'S ABOUT
DESTRUCTION.
DESTROYING PARENTS RIGHTS TO
RAISE HER CHILDREN WITH THE
VALUES THAT THEY SEE FIT.
NOW RACHEL'S VALUES MEMBER THEY
ARE BETTER, THEY ARE SUPERIOR TO
ANY PARENT WHO BELIEVES IN
TRADITIONAL GENDER ROLES BECAUSE
OF COURSE SHE WOULD BE MORE
CARING AND MORE INCLUSIVE AFTER
ALL IT IS AFFIRMING.
THAT ACCORDING TO ONE OF THE
YOUNG WOMEN WHERE THEY ARE NOW
IN THE PROCESS OF
DETRANSITIONING AFTER BEING
BULLIED BY SO-CALLED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL AND PUSHED ENTERED
GENDER REASSIGNMENT.
MEET CHLOE FROM CALIFORNIA.
>> MY NAME, TRANSITION OR FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AS MEMBER TRANSITION FROM 13-16.
THE TECHNIQUE TO SERVICE TO
AFFIRM MY MALE IDENTITY IN THE
THERAPIST DID NOT CARE OR
ENCOURAGE ME TO LEARN TO BECOME
MY BODY.
THE BRUSHED OFF PARENTS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE EFFICACY OF SURGERIES.
MY PARENTS WERE GIVEN TO MOVE
FORWARD IN MY TRANSITION.
>> Laura: THIS IS BEYOND
CONCERNING COMING ON PEOPLE YOU
THINK ARE GOING THROUGH THE SAME
GENDER IDENTITY INDOCTRINATION?
>> AFTER 2-3 APPOINTMENTS
INJECTABLE.
AT AGE 15 I ASKED TO REMOVE.
MY THERAPIST CONFIRMED MY
TRANSITION TEMPERATURE CLASS WAS
FILLED WITH AROUND 12 THERE WERE
MEN WAS FOR MY AGE THERE WERE
YOUNGER AND OF US WERE TO BE MEN
WERE 20 FOR ME A COMPARABLE
FEELING.
ALSO KNOWINGLY CUTTING OFF MY
TRUE SELF AND MY BODY AND
PAINFULLY.
>> Laura: THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER MEDICAL
GROUPS IN THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY SUPPORT
THIS CHRIS MARCH IS SUCH A
SCANDAL THIS IS CRIMINAL IS
CHILD ABUSE HIS KIDS DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
OR UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
PROCEDURES HAVE LIFE-CHANGING
CONSEQUENCES.
EVERY AMERICAN PARENT SHOULD
WATCH CLOSE GREAT TESTIMONY.
>> ARE IDENTITY'S WORK QUESTION
I WENT THROUGH THE SURGERY.
DESPITE HAVING THERAPISTS AND
ATTENDING THE TOP SURGERY CLASS
I REALLY DIDN'T UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THE RAMIFICATIONS OF ANY OF
THE MEDICAL DECISIONS THAT I WAS
MAKING.
I WAS INCAPABLE OF UNDERSTANDING
AND IT WAS DONE CONSISTENTLY.
MY PARENTS HAVE THEIR HAND WERE
PRESSURED TO PRESSURE MY
SO-CALLED GENDER JOURNEY WITH
SUICIDE THREATS I'LL NEVER BE
ABLE TO BREASTFEED A CHILD.
I BLOOD CLOTS IN MY.
I WANT ABLE TO EMPTY MY.
I DO NOT YET KNOW IF I'M CAPABLE
OF CARRYING A CHILD THE FULL
TERM.
IF THAT EVEN THE DOCTORS WILL BE
UPON PURITY BLOCKERS DO NOT EVEN
KNOW.
>> Laura: THIS MUTILATION OF
OUR CHILDREN IS WHAT THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY NOW STANDS FOR
PROBABLY.
ALLOWING WITH ONE OR MORE
PORTIONS BUT JANUARY 6 SMEARING
EVERYONE THEY DISAGREE WITH THAT
IS RACIST, FORCING YOU TO BECOME
PART OF THE GREEN FANTASY AND
FUNDING HOPELESSNESS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY THINK
AMERICANS WILL VOTE FOR NOVEMBE